[Music]
Lucy Ray
bear sing your way out of this one Lucy
gray what is that dress she's some sort
of clown
luy gray I didn't know I didn't know I'm
[Music]
sorry h how tantalizing to see all your
shining young faces on this auspicious
day I am Dr Bonia Gaul your humble head
game maker in charge of the war
department and all its Affiliated
concerns I broken free of my laboratory
today to examine you the leaders of the
Next
Generation I won't be around Forever
After
All
and now to that end I am honored to
introduce to you the creator of The
Hunger Games
themselves Dean Casa High
Boton select
students
faculty and of course Dr
Gul I have summoned you all here today
for the 10th Annual reaping ceremony in
which we choose two children from each
district to throw into the capital Arena
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games five Jess
4 3 Jess
run what are you doing
fr
[Music]
that girl's AR going to win these games
you saw her she's
underfed unstable the dean said it's not
just about winning everything is about
winning if not the games now then the
crowd Lucy gray won't survive a minute
inside that Arena so that means we have
to make every second before then count
I'll get have to sing again I wouldn't
sing a note for you if I was her I
wouldn't do anything at all unless I
could trust you she's District Tigers
she knows we hate her and she wants us
dead how am I supposed to get her to
trust me imagine it was your name that
they both and you had been ripped from
your home I just want to know that
somebody still cared about me out here
don't discount her just because she's
District Coro you might have more in
common with her than you
[Music]
think how tantalizing to see all your
shining young faces on this auspicious
day I am Dr Bonia G your humble head
game maker in charge of the war
department and all its affiliated
concerns I am honored to introduce to
you the creator of The Hunger Games
themselves Dean Casa High bottom I have
summoned you all here today for the 10th
Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each
district throw into the capital Arena to
fight to the death in The Hunger Games I
am here to tell you that there has been
a change this year one final assignment
to prove your worth
it's a story that takes place 64 years
before the first installment of the
movies and focuses on young snow look at
you your makeshift shirt and your two
tight shoes trying desperately to fit in
when I know the Snows don't have a pot
to piss
in snow is being groomed to become the
man he becomes as a mentor Your Role is
to turn these children into spectacles
not survivors persuade them
them to perform with the camera Lucy
gray the one who snow becomes the mentor
for and also falls in love with there's
a very naturalistic quality to her but
she's a charmer she's a musician she's a
performer she's kind of the anti catness
she's part of the cvy this kind of roing
band of musicians Snow's never met
anybody like her that romance between
them makes snow question everything he
was raised to believe
I think there's a natural goodness born
into us all you know really you can
either cross that line into
evil or not and it's our life's work to
stay on the right side of that line part
of the Love Story starts to fall apart
and that is part of the creation of who
he becomes it's the things we love most
and destroy us most everybody that I
work with is coming back Somerville is
doing the costumes for this movie y
Willams who shot Catching Fire the
Mocking Jays the one new person that I'm
really excited about is ulie Hanish
who's the production designer we talked
about the sort of look and the feel of
the movie The visuals of this movie will
be very different than mocking J but
there's real consistency in terms of the
capital architecture we get to sort of
reinvent the world of penm to sort of
deconstruct what the games are that
we're sort of used to and go back in
time it wasn't until I read it that I
saw how much music was actually in here
and we met with Dave Cobb he's a
fantastic songwriter and producer it's
going to be fun to take all this history
of britishes music and southern music
and mash it all together in this
dystopian way and this future James
Newton Howard it's my fourth Hunger
Games Film with him the musical
opportunity is
great relationships are very powerful in
the movie the good and the bad are very
clearly laid
out for James and I it was was really
fun to explore a new sound for The
Hunger Games sometimes it's foot
stomping and rousing and sometimes It's
haunting mysterious and a lot of that is
based on the kind of period of the movie
itself but there's going to be some
familiar elements as well Hanging Tree
is back in a completely different
iteration and treatment here we get to
see Lucy gray coming up with it for the
first
time
are
you are
you coming to the tree where I told you
to run so we' both be
free strange things did happen here a
stranger would it be if we met up at
midnight in the
Hanging
[Music]
Tree Mr
snow after everything you've seen out
there in the
world what are the Hunger Games
[Music]
are the Hunger Games they're to punish
the districts those tributes don't have
a
choice Your Role is to turn these
children into spectacles not
survivors free we're
live smile it's why we have teeth
imagine it was your name that they
pulled it strange
things I just want to know that somebody
still cared about me that I was still of
value welcome to the capital you look
like you shouldn't be here I shouldn't
but I'm your Mentor a
rebel I am going to get you out of here
you want to protect
people and it's essential to accept what
human beings
are and what it takes to control the
let's see you use that famous snow
charm you seem like a good man Corina
snow I have seen what war does to
people fued with the tur of becoming
prey see how quickly we become
Predator I want my enemies to see a
rainbow of
Destruction engulfing the
world
your monsters all of
you good luck with that poor little song
bird where is
she it's mystery and Mysteries have a
way of driving people
mad Mr snow let me ask you one final
time what are the Hunger Games
oh a
Hanging
[Music]
Tree it's the things we love most that
destroy
[Music]
us